Thanks ok hello everyone today we are
going to talk about bio inspired from
engineering so I'm Kylie I've been doing
from and engineering for more than help
a decade so this is my the link to my
github profile you can follow this link
actually I've been trying to get into
the twitter thing but and you know I I
wasn't very too successful so if you are
interested to follow me on twitter you
can use the same hand though it's just
it's the same but i'm not going to
injury included here just in case you're
interested so i'm currently working as a
staff engineer a kkbox IQ in taiwan and
doing a sort of you know from n and
javascript stuff and now i'm not sure it
is also common place for everyone's home
country but here in taiwan a good
portion of them from engineers in the
industry aren't you know i'm coming from
a computer science background so
including me so just being curious well
we are added so how many of you aren't
coming from a traditional computer
science background please raise your
hand please just in curious it's like um
a dozen or more people and okay so it's
not it's not a lot of people so maybe
I'm you know I'm not a common people and
I don't know so okay well just like like
I've said before I'm not coming from a
computer science background my academic
background is actually having nothing to
do with computer science at all so
actually I used to be a telescope
operator um manalo are in the Big Island
of Hawaii so it's not a very big
telescope either is a radio telescope
and we're trying to you know observe
some cryptic
properties of the microwave background
radiation so it's not very interesting
but I have a long-standing passion for
astronomy since my youth actually I'm
and giving my school years Mike timid
years i'm starting chemistry and biology
molecular biology cellular biology and
so on so i would not say they are
interesting but they can be enchanting
at links so you may be wondering that
like astronomy chemistry biology these
things sounds totally different again
there are you may think they're
unrelated to each other but actually I'm
trying to let you know that all of them
are like becomes a beacon of light point
into some of the archaic making the most
ancient and most profound questions for
us human being since the dawn of
civilizations so you may not notice yet
but they also have some striking
resemblances in places that you may have
yet to discover so maybe you would think
that this claim is very in like you
beers unbelievable but after all you
will see because while you may think
that the differences is astronomical
versus atomic home you know how can they
be you know how can I share any
resemblance is how could it be well it's
not only orders of magnitude apart we
are basically talking about two very
different ends on the scale of our
universe right so how could that be any
calculate here any kind of responses you
know so let's take a look at this
picture you know this background picture
what is it what does it look like to you
does it look like a group of cultured
cells on the package or maybe it's like
a representation of our neural network
in a brain
now that the answer is the real answer
is this is a computer simulation of the
Prairie based on real observational data
that's the very large structure of our
universe it's the largest known
structuring out your universe we are
calling it like a full amount of our
universe so as you can see our our
galaxy's you know that skitter doesn't
really scatter around the universe
layout you know they sit down certain
filaments along a straight a string a
straight line and there's nothing
between it's just boy nothing else so
the simulated similarities in the
visuals not mere coincidence actually
scientists are saying that there may be
some system dynamics that we haven't yet
fully understand having been in play
here and you know this may be a more
in-depth research into this area may
show some you know unknown science so
let's take a look at another example so
here's something yeah it looks like an
embryo you know in very early stage
embryo now we actually have a
specialized turn for the symbology
ice-coated Maaloula so it's immortalized
a fertilized egg undergoing a few splits
like from a single cell with you like 16
or 20 or 30 two cells you know this is a
very early stage of a single life it's
only a few days after fertilization so
it looks like because it looks like the
memories so it's called a morula okay
you say let let him freeze now
apparently this is not a fertilized egg
this is not a very well so I'm not
otherwise I won't be showing here so
it's actually a planet planetary nebula
code asked
nebula it's a few thousand light-years
away from the earth so ironically this
planetary nebula or should I say every
planetary nebula is formed at the end
stage of a time star so comfortably
counter into two to the early stage in
brio well so when a red giant reaches
the end of its life spin it will kind of
like just explode well actually it's not
explosion but the actual kinds of
pushing the other show of it of itself
into the interest level there are steps
space and these materials will get
ionized they will form the nebula you
see here and in a core will like
condensed into a white dwarf and the
white dwarf will be left alone in a
space and undergoing a eternity of
thermodynamic death so and this this
chem is that this is the very real part
of the central star of this planetary
nebula and this will also be the fat of
our very own son so you know this is not
fiction this is going to happen some in
some distant future so maybe you think
this is a sad thing but I'm going to
tell you that this is not necessary as a
bad thing because if not of these dying
stars you know we won't be here today
life on Earth will never happen at all
because the planet is the planetary
nebula and the explosion of stars is
very crucial to the generation of life
so Pete a tiny embryo or a diner a star
they both play in several inseparable
part in the burst of life so that's
because we're all star children so more
than ninety percent of our bodies masks
were forged by some long gone star in
the distant past
some jacket jetstar that is so for
example if you are like 70 kilograms 63
kilograms of your body mass is made from
alan's forge in some distant past inside
the core of a star a giant star so well
that's because you know in the beginning
the beginning is the big man that is
there's all the hydrogen and helium so
every heavier element like lithium or
carbon are formed in a later date during
a process with code nucleosynthesis
which is basically in Creole fusions I
stars so elements that are substantial
to organic life-forms like carbon
nitrogen oxygen there won't be here
today it is not because of this process
so now that you can see that well as
charming and chemistry and biology you
know they are not that different or
should I say the both of them going to
some you know single greatest mystery of
all time the origin of life so they will
give answers to questions like how we
here and you know why we are here and
what a hack this is jae's calm damn it
this is not like philosophy Kong you
know so what are you talking about this
where's my refund damning I'm going out
I'm getting out no please please don't
do this okay or you know Thomas will be
mad at me yeah so what I would like to
really talk about is that why we are
here today Theresa do is talk so I'm
hoping that we can agree these three
things which is convey ideas and
thinking process trying to you know
exchange ideas and see how ideas flow
and
to let you know that maybe we should
value cross disciplinary knowledge and
how to draw inspirations from the nature
the universe and we will use a classical
example which is a class composition as
an example for our general talk so first
just making sure that everyone is on the
same page when we are using now we're
talking about yes six classes very
quickly so this is how yes this class
works I'm sure that most of you should
know this but just in case you haven't
seen this before this is how it works
and it can be you know translated to es5
in reality this road like this and as
you can see this is a well-known pattern
or you know for classical JavaScript
development so it's not nothing special
here and there's also subclassing in
year six which is which goes like this
you can extend from a base class and you
can use super kohls so it can be
translated down to es5 like this it's a
little bit more complex but it's nothing
really hot you know basically it's just
telling you that how actually you are
extending from the productive chain and
how you are doing this super cold so
that's a special here as well so maybe
more interesting is the another proposal
for es 7 which is a class property
declarations I actually still in a very
early stage I'd still in stage one but
you can use it today and it looks looks
like this previously you have to attach
some properties in the
but if you are using this news proposal
you can you know attach the property of
class like this in Tucson I'm makes it
moral feels like a more integral part of
the class so and you can do you can do
all this stuff if you are using better
already but just in case you don't know
about this you can go to the Lebel
website and you know grab grab the
excuse it's good to the ball and you
know try experimenting some of this new
syntax and there's also a ripple a trip
or you can get to play about so let's go
through some quick back so first um yes
six classes are designed to be maximally
mini mall so what it what does this mean
maximal Ludmilla my so so strange you
know well the actually it means that the
committee spend a lot of time trying to
make sure that they put the tiniest bit
of things into the new specification
while enabling it to do a lot the
maximum the possible things yeah so
that's why they only settle down some
very basic features like extend and
super cold so there's nothing like
mixing centrist and so on so and just
make sure that you know this year six
classes is not actually a classical
inheritance it still protocol and it's
just trying to formalize on a very
specific pattern of the protocol in
Hilton's which is the constructor
pattern because everyone seems to be
using it so it's not actually trying to
actually trying to unburden the function
key word because before the es6 error
function key words you know being used
in so married so
so many places like you know declaring a
method that construct turn a call back
whatever and you are seeing this cure
everywhere so this is actually a good
thing for static analysis and
readability you know because it makes it
more clear that what you are trying to
do with this block of code and conveys
convey your intent more clearly so so in
my humble opinion yes six classes appear
at xle where the next level of language
abstraction would appear and yeah it's
just here for our usage but you know
there are a lot of naysayers and during
the formalization process and even now
there are a lot of people who are
opposed to this news feature but I'm my
take is this technology by itself has no
good of evil and the same should apply
to technique so what really matters is
the intent the intent of doing same
thing why are you doing this it's not
actually the technology or the technique
itself so there are some you know some
high-profile figures being very vocal a
cup about you know the inclusion of
classes in year six but i think the
inclusion itself is neutral it's what
you are trying to use it on that matters
so one of the biggest reasons develop
housing you know classical inheritance
or inclusions itself is because of the
fragile based class problem which means
that you know something bad will happen
if the injury emergence chain gets too
long like for example you can citizen in
a lot of places like for example in CSS
basically CSS itself is a giant inherent
in style sheets
you know it's called cascading style
sheets after all so you know each style
applies to cascading down you know the
stout stellar chain and basically the
whole design of CSS was encouraged
encouraging the use of Global's so this
is a bad thing for developers and
developers have been struggling with
this for so long and there's also the
extending sauce you know while extent is
very powerful it can cause some troubles
for if you are using in a round pattern
or just using it in a round time yeah so
there are actually a lot of you know a
lot of online tutorials or tutorials
trying to tell people when and when you
should you and when shouldn't you use
extending sauce and you know this is
weird by itself because it's if
something is good and you shouldn't have
to worry about this yeah you know you
should be not very prone to error and
now the thing is the you know the scope
chain in angularjs I basically a very
long productive inheritance chain down
each scope so I it's also been you know
very prone to error and a lot of people
have been complaining to this but i'm
not sure if there is any good solution
to this problem maybe he's a maybe
there's one it's you know i'm not sure
this is in angularjs but overall you
should do conversation over in here jens
if if the situation allows cause long
and shaky convergence change is very bad
and it's very not very easy to handle
with so you know if you you pinned here
yesterday maybe you heard the one both
talked about CSS modules
so on the I CSS format yawn if you've
been here yesterday then you should know
about this new solution used state of
art in the front end development area I
like you know we can use CSS modules to
marginalize the CSS we're using and
avoid the global scholarship problem and
maybe you should stop using cascading
after all at all don't use it and you
know and it says modules also provides
some capabilities upper class
composition and itself can notify the
problem of SAS extend and for angularjs
maybe you should check out really rare
for you know for a healthy work maybe
because react process is doing this in a
very different fashion than the scope
channel thing gorgeous so by design it
avoids the problem at all so just in
case you haven't check out react already
you can you know go figure it out on
their website they have a very extensive
documentation and here's a little bit
about remixes and basically there was
there was a mixing implementation in
react prior to version 0.2 thing when
you're using the old react react class
method we can do that is but after a new
update several most before they you know
they strip is the way so if you are
trying to use es6 quiz riad there is
nothing you can do now you know to
include the mix-ins which is you know
it's kind of sad you know you know yeah
because pure in the mixing IP artisan
react you should know that this is very
essential part of react because it helps
a lot to reduce the performance to
improve the
of the page so there was a debate over
the internet about you know trying to
bring mixings back to es6 react
components but my tech is that this is a
bad idea because mixing sentries have
their own problems now they're men their
main problem is that there are two too
weird or delhi uses because both mixing
centrate trying to address a problem
which is when the method overlaps they
are trying to resolve the method either
either implicitly or explicitly like for
example mixings is doing this implicitly
so for example like in ruby me by my
memory serves me correct in ruby it will
try to resolve your mixing in a right
first depth first order and in python
there is a another very delicate
operation code c 3 linearization that's
trying to you know do all this thing for
you but the problem is is to influence
it and you don't know what happening the
honest thing so there's another you know
conversation method which is trades is
trying to do this explicitly so you have
to you know declare on each method what
you are trying to do with this method
when there is a you know conflict so
they are few a few options like you know
symmetric song which is addition and
removal or you know renaming but it is
getting to you know excessive for your
daily use if you're not going to want to
do this for all your message if you are
you know maintaining a large scale
project this is going to be a lot of
work and you know the chances you are
using this is new nearly zero future so
maybe not
using this approach so that's where I
start to explore some alternative
methods for composition which led me to
the following inspiration so I start
trying to look for you know some
naturally occurring structures and it
turns turns out that sells the vesicle
component for life is a very very good
example for you know for this case and
we're going to go through this very
quickly I hope because this is not you
know maybe not very interesting to some
of you but we have to learn some basics
about cells it is one of the most
interesting and molecular structures of
our universe because you know there's
nothing like life and it has do with
students of revolution to come to this
current state and it's the so far the
only known fundamental and universal
building block of life so what's the
secret and maybe wishes from you should
do it from the very beginning of life
let's talk about how light begins so
actually there is no definitive answers
here to this problem but the most common
thing you know Syria right now is a
biogenesis which means that you know
life basically happens at a very deep
sea floor and there are a lot of like
hydrodynamic bands you know screwing hot
hot springs from the core of the earth
and life forms there because it provides
heat and the necessary chemicals or you
know reaction is
to begin kicking off some biochemistry
process and he also provides some you
know necessary environment to form the
the membrane of the cell so we have
mentioned that the formation of the
membrane of the cell is very important
because without a compartment you can Co
it a cell so this is the first thing we
are going to look at I've been trying to
avoid this kind of diagrams but you know
this is unfortunate we have to face it
you know we have to face it some some of
my children's talk I don't want this son
like some some [ __ ] from the
textbook but yeah let's face it so this
is a protocell but actually it is not a
sale it's just a ball being informed by
a you know a nut so sick or later so all
these all these small molecules here are
each are a 000 molecule and a very good
good way of thinking what it is is that
you can think of it as a you know an
object and naturally occurring object
and is it an empty object is not
something just an empty object so well
some some people are not very acceptable
to the idea that life kind of cell
originated but think about this it takes
the earth a billion years to build a
empty object no did not that's not very
small right so if you come to think
about this it's not very you know very
surprising so someone you know some more
millions of years later and there are
some more advanced not so advanced but
more advanced than a protocell sales cup
of code prokaryotic cell though which is
basically bacteria okay so as you can
see in this diagram
inside a prokaryotic cell there's
basically no structure at all so a very
good way of thinking about this is that
you know think about pojo tango java
squared an object we're playing with ja
sweet ya just bring our JavaScript
objects so how do we use a plain old
java object you know there's basically
no structure you just open a lot of
properties and throw integers and
screens and methods and bullying's and
all kind of things inside and this is
what you are seeing here you know there
is no compartments you know DNA and RNA
and all kind of stuff are you know
mixing together inside the compartment
so you know it's it's actually not a bad
design I'm not sure I'm not here to
judge but you know it gets things down
so come to think about this a you know
the heaviest biomass on earth is formed
by clock down which is pro Celtic and
productive life form but you know they
can form something to advance because
you know this kind of structures can
only can only go so far but they are
still nowadays very efficient you know
they can get in town but yeah just go so
far so after some more millions of years
you know after some interesting process
a more advanced more domest a variant of
sales emerged which is called eukaryotic
cell which is are what we are formed you
know everyone here your body is won by a
lot of product chaotic cells which is
the you know so far the most advanced
kind of self and the advanced cars they
have a lot of you know components you
know components encapsulation structure
you know all these are good things so
just look at it you know this is sang
good stuff you know it's like a real
component instance with a lot of light
metal hooks for your usage so another
interesting thing to think about is that
you know there's a not so small gap
between a prokaryotic cell and the
eukaryotic cell you know there's so much
more structure so much more compartments
actually they have a specific name code
a organelle okay now it's like literally
a small organ so there are a lot of
organelles here and how did how do they
come into its existence you know this is
another unanswered questions in
Canterbury contemporary science but
there are some very convincing series
right now that tries to address these
problems want them one of which is
called a sim biogenesis process which
basically means that you know our
primitive cell ancestors try to it is
eat some some other cells and they found
out that you know instead of eating them
fisting on them they can try to coexist
with them so a whomped example is the
psycho past which is what you will find
in all the plant cells SATA place itself
is believed you came from symbolic
Genesis so their ancestor is very likely
some you know some germ some
cyanobacteria and you know in some
ancient ancient has you know some cells
try to get this kind of small cells and
after they eat them they found out that
you know instead of shared them and you
know feast on their substances it's much
more better to your let them stay there
and you know that they do their stings
because it's actually they are basically
some
you know sugar generating factory so you
know free sugar why not so you know so
they just stayed and co-evolved with you
know some primitive cells and this also
happens for another organelle another
cell organ called mitochondria so you
know the odor is actually first there's
mitochondria cause coexisting with
primitive cells then call a tow rope
last so a lot of this process happened
in ancient times that we are not yet
very sure that happened or not but we
believe that is the one of the very
possible hypothesis about the
origination of Advanced Cell so come now
that we have come to know about this how
about that you know learn from the
nature and try to implement this kind of
structuring our code so while inspired
class composition so let's tweak our
earlier implementation a little bit we
are not going to declare a organized
organism we are going to define a cell
instead so here are a few you know
properties for sale age the amount of
glucose molecule and you know there are
actually energy molecule but I'm not
going to explain here they are just I'm
going just to represent them in some
drought in the integer and there is also
a very basic method code grow okay so
very basic and you know grow basically
consumes energy and grow the cell and
increases age and hear how we would like
to define our mitochondria and
chloroplasts cause basically in essence
they are still sells you know they still
preserve a lot of trades trade about
cells they hid their own DNA they have
on our a synthetic process and you know
a lot of similarities with a normal self
so we're just you know extend them as a
best class of using the cell as a best
class and mitochondrial is actually like
this you know power plant for ourselves
so it creates energy you know it
consumes glucose and turns them into
some energy molecules know the ratio is
not actually 12 wine but i'm not i'm
trying to keep things simple here so
there's also chloroplast chloroplast is
not do those simple things that they use
the energy from photon the light and you
know some or carbon dioxide and
transform you know somehow generate
glucose and oxygen now this can be a
little bit daunting but you know just
I'm going I'm just going to let your
skin test this really quickly but if you
are interested we have a link to the
code later so basically I'm you know
defying some more messes for a client
cell you know it can basically the main
things that it can do something like you
know divide an exiting micro country to
make it into tube and there's also some
way to channel energy and glucose
molecules we sing the cell and its
Oconee organelle right between you know
set up past and mitochondrial and this
is how we use it you know when you know
just the same with new a plant cell then
we can you know invoke the masses
attached onto it and if you are
interested here's the result and a link
for you to play it links to a paper
wrapper page which you can you know try
to play around and see if you can find
something more interesting now this is
more like a proof of concept so
you know if you are trying to do
something you can add more abstractions
into it I'm not I didn't add too much
abstractions because I'm just trying to
get the point across but you know
there's so much potential to this new
way of class composition but actually
I'm trying to tell this is I'm letting
you know that I'm being honest here this
is I seriously doubt that this is the
first time someone using this technique
because this is actually not a very hard
technique right so for example if you
are trying to explain this to a
five-year-old you can just say something
like oh I'm you know Instant agent in
some you know some objects in the
constructor method no that's basically
it but the point is what matters here is
that why you are doing this the
reasoning behind and you know the
different thing in the different
thinking process will use different
results in your scepter way for example
you know Flux Facebook flops you know
every if you have check into the
structure of flux structure in that you
will know that this is like basically a
mediator pattern in disguise but there
are some subtle differences or you know
details in in the flux structure to make
it shine through other similar
implementations so what's more important
is why you're doing this and the idea
you're thinking process behind and
perhaps now you you will come a little
bit closer to my ideas that cross the
circle mineralogy is somehow useful and
you can do not draw inspiration from the
nature because you know it's like a
giant simulation playground and the
nature is doing older hard looking for
you and coming out some of the best you
know that's way of doing things
so look around the nature and also it's
not necessary not necessarily a bad
thing to you know do the same thing that
other people have done before because
for example the eye the eye the window
of a soul has been you know evolved or
like 50 to 100 times independently no
it's not a single shot it's has do a lot
of evolution and so long independently
so you know there are actually a lot of
kind of eyes existing on this earth
there are some sea animals that can see
like you know a lot more colors than
humans can can do so yeah it's not
necessarily a bad thing so yeah so how
about we you know pay some more
attention to our environment and you
know maybe there are some inspirations
with him to be drawn okay now thanks for
you know thanks for watching thank you